[Music]
governments today are grappling with the
change brought about by technology the
shift in demands of citizens
expectations and service standards has
created a new need for governments
worldwide to seek new definitions of
design and delivery gx now tracks key
governments across the world in the hope
of finding answers to what governments
of tomorrow
will look like how they will deliver
excellence and why
experiences may be the key to unlocking
the value behind government citizen
engagements
gx is an idea
born out of the united arab emirates
created to fulfill the promise of
government service delivery and changing
it to an experience
the model is now slowly evolving to
become a template that can be used
globally to create government service
delivery excellence
in gx now you will hear a collection of
global perspectives coming from both the
public as well as from the private
sector the opinions of guests in this
documentary are to a huge extent based
on their experiences of working with
governments and being at pivotal
positions where governments and the
private sector interface
looking at some of the biggest
opportunities ahead and also some of the
challenges governments must face in the
next few years gx now is the story of
dreaming big of excellence of
changing perceptions and of creating a
better future for government services
worldwide
my name is ian khan thank you for
joining me on this journey
[Music]
if you look at the current state of the
government experience domain there
really isn't a standard everybody across
the world is doing things differently
and there's an impact of different
industries on government experience in
some parts of the world government
experience is dictated by the retail
sector and we make a comparison between
retail services and government services
what is happening within governments is
also in after effect of how other
industries are serving their clients
their clientele and their client base
governments across the world are trying
to adapt to different things and in
times of political instability changing
governments the priorities of
governments are changing
[Music]
let's talk to jonathan reichenthal i
spoke to jonathan about his experiences
and the challenges that he's seen
governments have across the world now
jonathan works with governments from
asia to the middle east to the americas
and in europe as well and he knows the
pulse of governments and the challenges
that governments are facing jonathan is
a big advocate of change as a professor
as an educator and as a business owner
his thoughts are critical in helping us
understand where we should go and what
governments should do in order to
progress
[Music]
one of the things i'm observing is i
have the privilege to visit many
different governments and cities around
the world it's number one
a recognition that
communities
have much higher expectations of service
delivery today
and so
if you're a community member you know
you're used to using consumer apps on
your smartphone or going to a website
and then you
use a government service and it's not
nearly as good or perhaps it's not even
digital the sense is now that this is
becoming you know no longer acceptable
we have to step the game up one of the
participants of the gx program is jane
wiseman i spoke to jane about what are
the challenges of government and what do
governments in the western world face
especially in the united states and what
are her experiences of government
service and government service
excellence half of americans can't tell
the difference
between
a google search result and a google ad
we need better data literacy so that we
can be
savvy about what are reliable sources of
fact
tim unwin is unesco chair in ict and
he's also professor at the royal
holloway university in london tim brings
a lot of experience when it comes to
working internationally at a grassroots
level and what's the state of government
experience and services in europe
in many countries of the world people
don't trust their governments and i'm
speaking from my experience in africa
they often are willing to trust the
private sector rather than governments
so i think there's some really
interesting things around that but if
people don't trust
governments they're not going to be
willing to
engage with those service provision
unless of course the government makes it
essential that they do so through their
digital systems i remember yeah a few
years ago many countries were saying
we're going to go digital by default but
that automatically excludes those who
aren't digital people with disabilities
elderly people they are going to be
marginalized by any move to government
services unless alternative mechanisms
are put in place so actually
you're going to need to provide service
centers where people can come to so
digital by default will marginalize
marloes pomp who's the head of
blockchain and the head of ai
partnerships for the government of
netherlands is an amazing resource she
has so much knowledge and information
because she works with other governments
from across the world as head of
blockchain and some very critical
programs by the government of
netherlands marloes knows what
challenges of governments are when it
comes to technology implementation
in the netherlands the government has
selected five key technologies like
blockchain artificial intelligence big
data cyber security and 5g and we will
invest in this technology more in the
coming years to improve these services
we try to build human-centric
applications it also means that we have
a lot of folks on the risk of these new
technologies for example the government
already uses
a lot of ai in in their services but of
course there's also the risk of
discrimination so that's why the
ministry of justice has launched a
guideline for all the governmental
services who are using new technologies
like artificial intelligence
i also spoke with the head of
e-residency for the estonian government
oath weather has been working for the
government estonia for many years and he
brings a lot of experience when it comes
to working with startups working with
international bodies international
governments and he shared some really
critical insights when it comes to
government experience and what does the
e-residency program hold and why is it
such a great example of creating
government experience that is seamless
and it adds a tremendous amount of value
for any country of any size
the difference between government
services in eu in asia in u.s is
very large and
the eu has some similarities here but
again looking at conservative countries
who do not have maybe that amount of
trust for the government or government
keeping their data safe which is also
very important then these services
cannot develop looking at countries like
india
who's rolling out
an identity program as well but 1.3
billion compared to our estonia is 1.3
million is a bit of another challenge
estonia is one of the biggest examples
that is used when it's about government
using technology and creating efficiency
in what governments do i spoke with the
cio of the government of estonia seems
secret we talk about what his challenges
have been and how he sees the government
experience changing from an estonian
perspective
our main approach is to make services
invisible as much as we can let's not
focus on interactions that's focusing on
you know delivering a value rather so a
value is for example that we ensure
compliance that's why we ask the
entrepreneur for some sort of report
even if we ask it online and my point
here is being that if we think about
from that perspective we often see that
we don't need to design for those
individual interactions and services we
can get rid of many online services
literally by automating things away
and so
if you leave the philosophy aside what
it practically means that we're trying
to in estonia at least kill
different
online services we built up by adding
more automation adding more sort of data
integration a bit more small data
analytics and stuff like that one of the
first of approaches on that parents of
newborn babies don't have to apply for
parental benefit it's automatically been
sort of granted for them we are building
it up for companies that if companies
will consent and agree the government to
have access to the financial records or
you know let's say data that is digital
anyways then we won't ever bother them
with a report not for tax not for
employment not for statistics not for
annual reports so forth all these things
the companies can now do online why do
we bother them with an extra step if we
have the data it's done
[Music]
there are definitely outliers and
there's definitely countries that are
making a solid effort in the right
direction to fully understand the
commitment that the government of the
united arab emirates has provided to the
government experience initiative and to
set forth a precedent in government
service delivery i spoke with someone
who's leading these efforts at the prime
minister's office in the uae muhammad
in the past the focus was more on how we
built the services in terms of processes
in terms of transforming services from
being a manual to
becoming automatic
and paperless however the customers
today
look
for services that are more towards their
experience
in other parts of services in the world
that they are familiar with and they
would like to see government services
being delivered in a similar way or even
better
[Music]
elin bijani is the ceo of the merged
alpha team group in the uae the much
defutab group is one of the largest
groups managing retail in the middle
east alain shared a lot of critical
insights how the retail sector affects
government how governments can learn
from the retail sector ellen also works
for the world economic forum and
different governments and bodies in
creating start leadership ideas and
initiatives that affect governments
worldwide the foreign industrial
revolution is a reality we're in it and
i would say it's very important that the
rate of change on the inside
be at least equal if not if not faster
than the rate of change on the outside
it's also allowing us to be able to deal
with some of the endemic issues that we
couldn't deal with before technology
today presents that capability to do
that and it's becoming more ubiquitous
more affordable and more simple to use
it's now on us our generation of leaders
to make sure that we turn this into the
opportunity that it actually is and to
make sure that we can drive sustainable
economic growth employment creation job
creation and we can drive a better
integration of our societies in the
world
[Music]
fadi al-hindi is the ceo of an ai based
company focused within the insurance
industry but he brings a lot of critical
insight to the idea of gx over the past
maybe five to eight years customers are
no longer willing to tolerate delays or
lack of transparency or not knowing
what's the next step or being mistreated
for that matter historically the economy
was more like product driven in the 70s
and then you get into the 80s and the
90s and now it's more moving towards
like a relationship economy we live in
the experience economy and i think this
is something that you will see more and
more and more when you think about the
effort that we're putting together
across the board private center public
sector and how we're all trying to put
everything around the customer make sure
that the customer is actually the
epicenter and how can we actually from a
government standpoint contribute to
their quality of life contribute to
their well-being take away all the
uncertainties that come with it and give
them the ability to focus on what they
would like to focus on what they love
most and what they like best which is a
service that's one curated around them
two that is there when they need it and
actually think about what does the
customer slash citizen need and not what
does the government need for very long
time governments have been focused on
actually
designing services or they're
implementing
those designs in a way that suits the
governments from different perspectives
and i think what we're seeing here is
actually a total reversal
[Music]
i spoke with government in azerbaijan
and the head of the assan service center
the assange service centers have
completely changed the idea of service
delivery by bringing together different
vendors and as many as 300 plus services
at one place it has radically changed
how government is delivering services at
a service center level traditional ways
are not suitable anymore to provide our
services and to get satisfaction level
but also we know that it's not only
about technologies it's also about
organizational structures it's about
human resources and we are trying to
build suitable environment in order to
provide our services effectively and
efficiently to our citizens
where the government has placed an
incredible emphasis on this is the
recognition that everyone is different
and
a tremendous experience is often not
something that is entirely frictionless
like booking a train ticket it's not
that difficult to say what is the
station you need to go to what time
where are you leaving from and how many
passengers are there that's a very
automated process that has
almost no variation
but
when you're trying to change your name
and actually
the options that you're going for are
not available but when you're trying to
consume
healthcare services and you have
two children who are naturally born one
is adopted
these are the type of unique situations
that actually
when organizations are able to deal with
that effectively that's what makes
people feel really good about it because
it makes it feel like we actually
understand that there are very
personalized requirements that citizens
have
if you sit at home how is your feeling
about the services you get from the
government are you worried about missing
out or forgetting about paying your
bills your utilities built
or are you comfortable because you know
that it will automatically
be processed through your digital
assistant that kind of level and that
kind of experience is what we're seeking
where a customer does not need to worry
everything runs in the background on
their behalf consuming government
services anywhere in the world
is normally met with the thought of
bureaucracy and lots of paperwork i
think what's different here is that
there has been a incredible focus on
making sure that the pain and the
friction that normally is involved with
the yearly renewal of services
has been taken away now whether that is
having your car renewed which is almost
entirely a digital transaction now
and whether that is your national id
or whether that's just paying for your
parking through your mobile phone
everything is now interlinked and what's
very neat is there's a single
portal app where you can then go on and
whether it's hospitals or funeral
parlors or government service centres
all of that information is now housed in
one place
[Music]
i saw a survey that three quarters of
ceos think that customer experience is
very important to their business
but there's no such survey in government
i don't know how many government leaders
think the customer experience is top
priority but i'll tell you there are 10
million government employees and it's
not top priority for everyone
so let's say you have to go to a place
you have to go to a physical place
what's the experience like when you get
there is it is it crowded and chaotic do
you know what to do do you get good
customer service do you talk to people
that are well informed and if they have
difficulty themselves getting you the
information do they have access to
information tools to help you
as a community member i think i see
governments now beginning to think about
the entire life cycle
of a process for example getting a copy
of your birth certificate when you want
to
submit a request for a permit which is
such a common city or government
activity it shouldn't be as hard as it
is today people don't look forward to
that and the experience should be better
you should be able to and increasingly
request a permit online without having
to go to a place
and take a number
and wait and spend half your day
in a government office in the united
arab emirates we focus on customer
experience from their live instances so
for example if the customer has a
newborn baby we look at that as an a
point of life where they need government
services
about
having a new baby therefore we started
looking at it from a bundling
perspective so instead of a customer
looking at which government entities or
or government service centers they
should visit they just know what bundle
they want i'll give you an example of
one of the services that we have it's
called mabrook mayak which means
congratulations on you your newborn
and it bundled more than seven services
into one step
and more than five payments into one
payment and to get everything related to
this newborn within three hours now
using this bundle
we are now moving from a one-stop shop
model to non-stop shop model in assam
service centers we are providing
reactive services to our citizens but
now we started launched new project
which is called mygov my government
project and it's about providing
proactive services to our citizens for
that we are very widely using beta in
order to predict expectations of our
citizens and
in house by the government we are trying
to involve the companies to this process
as well
as a result of really rapidly changing
world what is changing is also citizen
expectations citizens today expect a
different level of service at a
government level the expectations are a
combination of what they're seeing in
the private sector in the retail sector
in the healthcare sector and a
combination of this is leading to the
overall citizen need if you will for
service excellence
today citizens you and i we all use
smartphones and technology to make
decisions to access services and it's
very common just to expect that every
service should be available on a cell
phone should be available on a mobile
device but not all governments have been
able to translate services from a
service center to online
most
so-called governance agendas are
actually about governments providing
services to people through technology so
we can see uh government websites where
you can access
forms to fill in passports or licenses
or pay tax that is a really interesting
change of management structure in the
old days governments had lots of civil
servants lots of people working for them
to do the paperwork
now
the effort and load has been transferred
back down to the citizens it's like in
the old days when you might attend a
meeting somebody would send you all the
paperwork in advance you didn't have to
do anything you just read the paperwork
and
took it to the meeting now you're sent
the files digitally by email or another
online system or even you're expected to
go online to download those forms
yourself then read them then perhaps
print them off because you might need to
take them to the meeting so that is a
shift of labor from governments to
citizens or from organizations to
employees i hate having to log on to
three or four different sites every day
to get information whereas it could
easily just be sent to me in another
form the standard rhetoric is is of
course that it makes it much easier for
governments
and citizens to interact on key things
that they need to do and that
undoubtedly have its advantages it's
it's very easy now to submit a passport
application online or your tax forms
online second point though is and i'll
use the example of our own government
digital service there are many great
things about gov dot uk however if you
want to find out anything from the
government website about a government
department or what it does it's almost
impossible
and i think that is an indication this
difference between government service
provision and
the relationship between governments and
citizens and the openness and the
transparency around that
[Music]
today i think
citizens are co-creators in a government
experience
there's an opportunity for each of us to
be partners and help get stuff done a
greater openness in you know more
progressive cities and more tools for
collaboration are allowing community
members in particular to participate in
everything from decision making to
design sessions even development of
solutions there's some very interesting
experiments being done with community
co-funding identifying funds from public
sector and private sector to get
projects done that have been difficult
to get moving because of the reliance
purely on public funds if a government
makes available data and a community
member says hey i could build a solution
using that data
wow what that's a great relationship
that's a great partnership we have
software engineers now who can step up
create interesting solutions or try to
make sense of data and serve up the
analytics that helps decision makers
make better decisions that's a
relationship we've never had the tools
to be able to do before a good
democratic
government experience is not a spectator
sport
it's a it's something you participate in
state of washington is one of my
favorite performance driven
organizations
there's something called results
washington every single metric about
state government is available online
drill downs to get greater detail and
when the governor hosts a results
meeting the public is invited it's
streamed live online
but they also include a customer or two
or three in every single meeting so if
it's about youth development there are
actually youth there giving feedback to
the government about how the services
are improving where they need more
improvement so that's a great example at
the state level and right now 90 of our
federal government websites are
collecting customer feedback and trying
to iteratively improve my takeaway is
that it's really interesting what's
happening in the world today the amount
of data that is generated on a daily
basis
is just mind-boggling yet you talk to a
lot of the enterprises you talk to
government you talk to a private sector
you talk to large corporates
and they will tell you that they have
poor data issues with quality there are
gaps in the data
there's a problem there's a lot of
legacy systems and data that's out there
that's quite difficult to mine and bring
to the surface when you're building
something greenfield it's much more
simple to do that from from a to z but
the truth is a lot of government
departments have huge legacy of
information systems that they're using
and traditional processes so the
difficulty is trying to stitch those
together in a format that the customer
doesn't feel any bumps it's like having
a shopping trolley being pushed across a
railway track
very bumpy experience and what you're
trying to do is take all of those knots
out of the experience
[Music]
in all services you need a form of
identity but it's identity it sounds
like there's only one identity and i
expect you i have several identities
which you can use so i will use another
identity to log in in my for example in
my google account then i will use for
a governmental service for example i
hope these digital identities uh several
identities are owned by me and are
controlled by me the state of indiana
recently created a single sign-on so
that i can get my park permit bringing
my driver's license you know
certifications any government activity
that i'm doing with the state is all
under one id so that i don't have to
continually re-enter my information so
that's wonderful sort of one-stop shop
but you know we're still a long way from
being able to integrate from the federal
to the state to the local with a single
identity and i think it's probably worth
being careful about this because
with a single identity in government
comes risk you know could it be hacked
when it's done by the private sector
government doesn't have the control
and can't police it in the way that
might be necessary so for example in the
u.s we have for the ability to travel
the transportation security
administration is responsible for
issuing tsa pre-check you know so that
they vet me and then i can go in an
express lane well there's also a private
sector entity that's doing that what is
the fundamental role of government
should it be the government that says
who can get on a plane
and is safe to travel and who isn't
if you let the government have all of
your identity what might they do with it
i often
liken this to what happened
in rwanda where the use of older digital
technologies radio for example enabled
many parts of the genocide there to
happen more efficiently so if a
government knows everybody's identity
and where they live and everything about
them what can they do with that
information for migrants it's very often
issues around whether qualifications for
example
gained in one country can be compatible
with those gained in another country
imagine if everybody had a digital
identity that they could take with them
so that if you're moving from kenya to
south africa or from haiti to brazil
actually you can take your identity with
you i think that raises really exciting
possibilities not only for migrants but
also for governments if we could get
global agreements around what the
parameters and what the credentials in
digital identity meant that could be
really beneficial
[Music]
so it won't be one technology which will
solve the digital identity topic it will
be a combination and this moment we
really try to figure out how can we
combine
a digital identity with
privacy preserving technologies like
knowledge proofs or multi-party
computation i think this is a really
interesting area to explore at an
international level
[Music]
we believe in estonia that digital
identity is the backbone of everything
every person should have an identity
matched to them physically and digitally
so every estonian communicates with the
government using their digital identity
meaning they do everything from bank
statements taxes to registering the the
child birth using the digital identity
and we really can't imagine our life any
other way
it's been actually for us as a estonian
government the learning journey to get
to have experience in focus i'll be very
honest here i think we've been very
techy and engineer-led throughout our
beginning years especially in a sense
that seeing okay
how much
better how much more efficient we can be
if we functionally build things up and
you know for example put services online
whatever the experience
now we've really come to the point to
get to next level obviously experience
has to be at the forefront because
otherwise we don't have people as using
it and
and so it goes off course way beyond
just issues of nice neat design of an
online environment our core focuses is
how do we make the process the working
of government
into the best experience and in offer
case for us just to you know look
forward i mean it's about um how do we
simplify it radically because the best
experience at least as far as students
is concerned if there's none if stuff
happens for me as an estonian it's very
hard to give advice on physical service
centers because for us
digital journey has meant getting rid of
them
largely there is the tax board that has
a physical stand and perhaps the post
but otherwise if we talk about
governmental services they are 99 online
if you can't get access to digital in
whatever means because you don't have
connectivity you don't have electricity
you're going to be further marginalized
by the delivery of
digital services classic example is
around the notion of smart cities i
often say just by saying the word smart
cities actually implies villages are
fairly dumb so one of the main
challenges is very much that you can't
deliver say what you can in a small
densely populated area that has full
connectivity that's why it's so
important to have access in the first
instance not all our citizens are
technologically literate that's why we
need asean service centers in
all parts of our country
also we have mobile buses these buses
are
specially equipped with different
technologies we send that buses to the
remote areas where we don't have azan
service centers in order to serve our
citizens
and
also
we have volunteers the human factor
within the
government experience is the primary
factor from all perspectives i would say
so if it is from a customer perspective
or from a government employee
perspective even the employees who work
on delivering government services we
looked at their happiness level we
looked at how
they understand what customers want
therefore we have conducted a series of
trainings it's a customer happiness
training where we look at the front line
employees who provide the services we
train them on how to conduct business in
a manner that will make the customer
happier and also at the same time we
looked at the supervisors of these
government service centers which we call
in the united arab emirates customer
happiness centers and we train them on
how to supervise a team of customer
happiness officers i'm not in favor of
absolutely 100 abolishing every
government service uh physically because
we see that some regions for estonia
this is the kind of only form of
communication that some of these people
actually have and they enjoy these forms
of communication they enjoy going to the
post office but in terms of city life
the terms of actually going to to the
tax office and waiting three hours to
fill in a stack of paper that should be
eliminated absolutely
[Music]
the way to shape government services is
really clear we need across the board a
template of excellence we need something
that can be easily adapted easily
deployed for example if a country has a
model of excellence is that model able
to be replicated across different groups
across different departments and
ministries that's exactly what is needed
the gx program in the united arab
emirates is an excellent example of that
government service excellence is a top
priority for the government of the uae
things such as tweeting about the
rankings of government service centers
is not very uncommon in the uae and this
is how leadership runs the country gx
was created with a vision in mind to
drive the attention of people working on
services regardless to the type of
customers or the persona of the customer
we need to focus on the experience of
that customer now who is part of the gx
everyone so it could be private sector
it could be investors startups
entrepreneurs who could be part of the
gx platform has multiple aspects to it
we have the government services forum
that brings leaders from around the
world around the table to discuss
government services
we have the gx online platform that
shares knowledge base how governments
around the world improve customer
experience we have also the gx talks so
the gx talks also focus on getting
thought leaders from different
backgrounds to talk about experience of
customers whether it is digital
experience or it is also the physical
experience or even experience that has
no touch point so for example if you sit
at home how is your feeling about the
services you get from the government are
you worried about missing out or
forgetting about paying your bills your
utilities bills or are you comfortable
because you know that it will
automatically
be processed the uae is an impressive
nation they've got the advantage of
being fast and nimble and agile right
now in the way that they go after
initiatives plus they've got leadership
that's truly vested and believes in
going digital and adopting the fourth
industrial revolution i think these
ingredients when you put them together
gives you a very unique
environment because of the
platform that's been created by
investing in this futuristic thinking
it's not just their vision and their
talk but they're building things and
doing things i've been able to
experience these things firsthand in
dubai
for example their concept around the
future police station it's a beautiful
experience people feel safe a lot of it
is done by use of digital technologies
assistance from
the right resources via a video
conference which i thought was was
incredible you see a lot of
experimentation and prototyping you see
very bold projects everything from smart
dubai right through to the paperless
society thus making the cost of
government be less data to be more
accurate all the benefits we would
expect one of the big ones the
environmental positive side of not
having all this paper they're doing the
things they're demonstrating they're
experimenting they're helping other
communities and cities and governments
around the world see what's possible
sharing these insights with the world
and wanting to create things like the gx
forum which becomes a global platform to
say hey you know what there's different
ways
to have a government experience we've
got to be able to create channels that
takes these best practices the stuff
that goes well and maybe even the
learnings of the stuff that doesn't go
so well all the time and share it with
governments in every corner of the world
so i think the thing that's important
about it being an international
conversation and frankly being an
in-person conversation because we're all
busy if we just try to get together
by phone or webinar
we're going to get distracted but when
you
plant yourself physically with other
people you make the kinds of connections
that last
and that allow us to keep advancing the
ball to continue to
refine our thinking and to challenge
each other that sense of almost like a
healthy peer competition like oh i'm
gonna have to have something to say when
i get back together with this group you
know what have i done what do i bring to
the table so i think that's a real value
that we can see in this group it's
really necessary to have experiments
within your own organization because
otherwise it's too complicated to have
these discussions with other partners
who develop services so you must test
and explore a little bit within your own
organization you must train your
employees there are hardly any projects
where you don't have to collaborate so
it's really important to learn how you
can build firm coalitions and what kind
of agreements do you need
the legal issues around these
collaborations the governance models of
course it's very difficult to implement
ideas as it is because every country has
own culture has own tradition as own
environment and you can see how they
challenge in that environment and how
they solve that problems during the
implementation process initiatives like
this can often tend to be wanting to
come up with the best global solution
but these
ideas are evolving the relationship in
citizens states is evolving technology
is evolving so a little bit more i think
self-critique and not always positive
about some of the activities that happen
because technology can be used for good
and it can be used for bad and it's how
we how we mediate those in the interests
of citizens for me
citizens are actually more important
than governments governments should
serve their citizens
[Music]
we have learned from me residency
experience is to try to put yourself in
the shoes of the user because we see
quite often that that's what government
officials are lacking so they sit in
their silos and they don't talk to the
users they don't understand the needs of
the users in the age of smartphones and
all of the private sector services that
we actually consume all the time we
can't expect our governments to lag
behind
we believe in estonia that governments
can never compete with private companies
and they shouldn't but governments are
the ones who have to offer government
services so it's time to actually go
together with the trends what's
happening in the world
the global star rating program is the
first of its kind that assesses
government service centers as if they
are hotels so just like when you walk
into a hotel and you see that this hotel
is a five-star hotel and you understand
what experience you're going to be
getting from a five-star hotel the same
similar concept has been applied to
government service centers hijacking
guided us to make united arab emirates
government as efficient as banks and
works 24 7 like airports since this
program has been launched we have
realized the fruits of this program by
seeing customer happiness centers
improve significantly over the past
eight years the edelman trust barometer
ranks the ue very high the highest is
not the second highest in the region and
one of the highest in the world i think
with 84 percent trust the ue has always
designed its government services and
looked at government services as
actually an enabler to society today the
uae is looking forward and say i want to
do even more and even better i want to
be even more customer-centric i want to
make sure that my government services
are actually not just the best in the
world but the most satisfactory in the
world for the people that use them and
actually how can i enhance their life
how can i actually add value to their
lives and this is something that we're
seeing happening day in day out this
culture of transparency that's coming
across more and more in the uae in order
to be the best in the world we have also
to hold up the marriage and this is
something that you're seeing happening
and i think the government is leading by
example
[Music]
the future of the gx program by the
prime minister's office in the united
arab emirates is strong it's something
that's tangible it's something that can
be developed and adopted by every
government service program in the world
but it needs work it needs work because
implementation of these things is
complex you need stakeholders to agree
on these things you need to get the
buy-in from people who run governments
and those are some of the challenges
that other governments might face when
adopting this program we live in an era
of disruption fast changing expectations
in order to make the world a better
place we will have to play the game in a
different way whether it's gx or any
other program at a government service
level it needs the commitment of the
leadership of these countries of these
departments and groups so this is an
amazing time there is so much potential
and we need two things we need number
one to listen and number two to act and
when you put those two things together
it makes a huge difference
so
in the us the veterans administration
which serves former members of the
military who are now back in the country
they started a customer
satisfaction survey
and it turns out people who responded to
the survey and gave feedback
were four times more satisfied with
government than others now don't know
yet whether some of that is uh sample
bias that those who decided to answer
the survey were more satisfied but to me
it also says that there is power in just
asking for feedback when you engage the
public they become more excited the city
of santa monica california has a
well-being index they have decided that
the purpose of that city is to support
the well-being of its people one of the
things they've done is social media
sentiment mining so they can tell which
neighborhoods are showing through the
publicly available information on
facebook and twitter what neighborhoods
are under stress what neighborhoods are
worried about money and how can the city
really do something about that we now
have drug treatment in jails because the
people who were coming out of jails were
120 times more likely
than the average person to die of a drug
overdose so now we can do interventions
in our jails because the data approach
allowed us to target when
community members got to participate and
help the government choose where the
money goes when the people made the
decisions there was more investment in
health more investment in education and
some of those early cities that employed
this showed lower incidence of infant
mortality you know five years ten years
from now i think we're going to have a
much higher level of trust in government
because with all of these new ways of
engaging the public there are
untapped ideas and resources and
potential for
really making government just far better
than it's ever been we are planning to
implement personalized services for our
citizens from any country
from any place and without any barriers
and to be accessible and available for
that we need also to implement
new technologies ai machine learning
deep learning and other technologies now
we are implementing shared cloud-based
document flow system and it helps us to
reduce
the cost for building that services and
to optimize that processes
[Music]
the governments of the future are going
to be focused more on purpose and less
on services services are going to be
done artificial intelligence machine
learning is going to take care of most
of the services being delivered we're
going to be focusing more on thinking
about our future on how we can magnify
life as a nation as a community the
governments will have much more time
capabilities and much higher caution
when it gets to livability when it gets
to the future of government is going to
be about a lot of the problems that we
know today a lot of the topics that we
are trying to solve for today are not
going to be there in 10 years time we
are all going to be augmented in our
capabilities as human beings we're going
to be able to do more for less but also
we're going to be able to actually focus
on where we actually make the biggest
difference and drive the biggest impact
not in terms of the small things that
happen around us in terms of enriching
life on earth and how we can actually be
a continuous age of change and progress
[Music]
i believe that ai is definitely going to
be the next
cycle of major revolution in technology
and what we're going to be able to do
with it are a lot of products and
services that were not possible in the
past but it's not my belief that the ai
algorithm is going to become sentient
one day and wake up and figure out that
humans need to be eradicated let's be
more pragmatic and more realistic and
let's not worry about the sci-fi part
the part of ai that's really exciting
are
most helpful for corporate user or the
corporate worker the first one is this
concept of digital twin and the concept
of digital twin is that it's an
assistant that's working side by side
with the human to be able to improve the
quality of the type of work that they're
doing by relegating all the mundane
manual tasks over to the ai and the
automation so that the human is actually
focusing on the things that they should
be focusing on not following the papers
not thumbing through things and trying
to index um you know a thousand pages
that should all be done by machines and
the digital twin should be
providing this workflow automation for
the human to become more effective and
more efficient
a lot of services will be global
services and then on top of that or
besides that you will have a local
flavor
but what i see for example with the
blockchain projects the registration of
diplomas now it's done by countries by
themselves i expect this will be a
global service we bring people from all
these coalitions and all these
communities together to work on these
challenges which are
mainly global challenges and i think at
this moment the first step to bring
these experts together they need each
other for example the blockchain experts
they need more and more data and so they
need the experts from the big data
working group but also the data experts
from the artificial intelligence working
group so the next step is to build
broader collaborations worldwide and i
hope the netherlands can be the gateway
to europe for many services
the future of government services should
be something that happens without the
customer asking for it we know what the
customers want
why not deliver it to them why not go to
the customer instead of having a
customer come to us we want to relate it
more to the digital experience that
customers they have with online shopping
where they get recommendations on what
to buy based on their previous searches
on the time of the year we want to be
something similar to that and maybe even
more proactive we are aware that the way
education is going to be delivered is
going to change we are aware that
healthcare is going to change all of
these services need to be integrated in
a way and in a manner that makes it
seamless to the customer seamless to the
investor of the future we have taken
most of our services online already but
now it's the matter of actually
measuring the quality of these services
how do they function what could be
improved what's the journey behind it
you can do most of the stuff online but
we still have lots of relic
in the process in estonia when we opened
up our services to non-citizens using
e-residency that means that we might
have some estonian documents from time
to time pop up to the foreigners in our
systems that's something that needs to
be worked we're working towards the
perception of having this
seamless background services once you
are born we already know your name we
know your birth date we know quite a lot
of things about you same for medicine
for example we're looking at some of the
ways where we can predict what illnesses
you might have or what's genetic about
you and
and the like we've been very pragmatic
in a sense to say look let's figure out
how to solve this organizations legally
have proper safeguards in place
technologically as well so this sort of
approach to fixing problems and sort of
solving them in a very engineering way
even through design is is one part of it
and the other part we have benefited
from the fact that obviously we are a
small country in that sense and the size
doesn't matter really for the point of
view how many people that live but just
the i would say that as a small country
we have very lean governance in terms of
how decisions are made and i think if
often times if if countries ask me okay
so what makes a stone a bit more nimble
because decision making is faster and
not too many levels of government to
consult and so forth so so that's what
has allowed us to go quite a bit way and
i've seen in bigger countries too if
somehow decision making gets streamlined
of course in democratic context then
you're able to make leaps because tech
moves fast you have to be able to move
faster along as well
[Music]
what will really change the world is
when enlightened progressive governments
are able to easily connect with
enlightened
active citizens
because that's a potent force you bring
those two things together and we can do
some really amazing things this sort of
tension that exists between communities
and governments because you know
communities have great expectations the
governments try hard but they they
struggle to meet those expectations in a
digital world you can deliver more
consistently and getting access to
information and data when they need it
creating more of a seamless channel
between when the data is created by
government or collected by government
and the desire to be able to access that
simply because we want to know what
government is collecting on us but also
to be able to make better decisions
and to develop solutions
will be a much greater degree of
automation in the future and this will
be both in the digital world through the
use of artificial intelligence but also
through robotics and so we will have
questions about what does that mean to
the human experience what does that mean
to jobs
what does that mean to the personal
connection we have between an individual
and a provider so we'll see all the
positives of automation and artificial
intelligence we also got to be conscious
of what that means ultimately to us as
humans
we have to decide what we want to do
about that there'll be more change in
the next 10 to 20 years than in the last
100 years when it comes to government
experience it's gonna be a remarkable
time
all the different methodologies
available today including the gx program
are amazing they can change how citizens
are served they can change how citizens
you and i
access services at a government level in
the country of our choice i really
believe governments need to look at gx
as a program that can bring a new wave
of energy that can bring efficiency and
accountability in their governments
the united nations predicts that global
population will reach 9.8 billion people
by 2050. this means more expectations
from governments to serve citizens
better and create better experiences
this means a more complex world with new
stakeholders new challenges and new
speeds of response in 2020 humanity
battled a new challenge the kobit 19
pandemic many governments struggled to
cope with the pandemic and yet many
succeeded beyond expectations in
managing controlling and eliminating the
threat of the pandemic one thing all
responsive and successful governments
did was their ability to respond fast to
engage with citizens and to focus on
success while looking to the future it
is these governments thinkers leaders
and trailblazers that are in the process
of creating a better world
[Music]
[Applause]
if you believe that there is a social
contract between the governed and the
government
then the thing that governments need to
keep in mind when they provide services
is
what people really want to get from that
relationship
[Applause]
sometimes the solution that will work in
one place won't work in another so being
very
curious about the histories and cultures
in which you're working
in order to match up the services with
the particular residents or citizens
that they're serving i think is a real
leadership skill
making it an outside-in approach to
services delivery as opposed to inside
the government out is a change of a
paradigm of how government traditionally
develops and delivers policy and then
thinks about service delivery
challenges that governments face are no
longer technical in nature
those we figured out how to solve the
problems that are facing governments
today are more around
wicked problems such as how do we solve
homelessness
how do we improve
food delivery to people how do we
improve people's quality of life we
started with public policy focusing a
lot on markets and market failure and
how government had to solve problems of
market failure i think that's still an
important thing but i think we have to
go beyond that now and understand that
equity and justice are really important
factors that we have to take into
account and figure out how we can devise
public policies that make sure that
we're being equitable and we're being
fair and just there are places that are
excelling in doing digital services but
i have yet to see a government that then
harvests the data on the back end
customer insight for predictive
analytics you know geospatial analysis
and really optimizing performance just
because you have a large large data set
does not necessarily mean it can help
you
in any way if you can't unlock value or
information from that raw data and so
the way i think about how government can
play a role is to really focus on
information that's valuable for
constituents for policy makers for
citizens for residents for for visitors
use that information to all be on the
same page for what success looks like
and how to assess whether or not you've
hit criteria that you've set and then
ultimately
learn and iterate from there
today customers have expectations that
are drastically different than what
governments offer today as services and
we should bridge the gap i worry that in
a downturn we're going to have to be
even more efficient in the way we serve
and with the
expansion of digital services we need to
think about how we do old-fashioned
services in a new way one thing that we
do within a city can impact traffic
which can impact housing which can
impact
the migration of people we have to
consider everything within systems and
within the the
greater mechanisms of this and not just
on individual decisions make sure you
have the right business cases and the
right governance in place that you can't
innovate if it takes a year to approve a
business case to do a new service
[Music]
[Music]
the one thing that government needs to
focus on primarily is really trying to
understand community it's at the very
micro level of a city and
using technology is one way to be able
to do that but also being able to embed
themselves within
communities deeply to understand the
greatest challenges that people are
facing and then being able to use that
data in a way that can actually affect
change this next generation cares more
about issues like the planet issues
about housing equality
than previous generations but i think we
have to make government attractive to
them
[Music]